uh you sent me this governor newsome
the great governor the state of
california who by the way said recently
that he rejects these
republicans that want to try to recall
him okay yeah before we even play this
video that's a very good point
he said in a video all those california
republicans
that it was it was a republican plot
it was a republican plot to to get him
recalled
now of course that's not true a lot of
the people that have signed the petition
are just angry business owners that
aren't republican
so let's see it's very hard to find
republicans in los angeles san francisco
and san diego
and a lot of people sign from there so
let's see what he has to say
in an empty stadium good optics
let me uh i hate him i know he just
started very hated
i know he just started but i cannot
stand him
thank you madam lieutenant governor for
your elected and state officials
uh to my amazing wife jennifer uh our
first partner in the state
he's having a zoo meeting
in an empty stadium with
the zoom people on a screen next to him
is that what he's doing our first
partner of the state of california thank
you all
for being here in well the most and i'm
speaking to you
from dodger stadium transformed from the
home of last year's
world series champions into the
centerpiece of america's mass
vaccination campaign
instead of fans that's not dystopian
this feels like the opening to a movie
where like there's going to be a black
president yeah
morgan freeman like you're one of those
in the stands we see nurses in ppe
saving lives one injection at a time
fifty four thousand fifty four thousand
three hundred and ninety five
californians
we now mourn with broken hearts that's
almost the exact
same number of empty seats behind me
so
he's being criticized because he won't
open stuff up right
so this whole thing doing this at an
empty stadium
was to go you know enough people died to
fill up the stadium
yeah that's what he's doing but what he
doesn't realize is that
it backfired marking a silent tribute
to loved ones who live forever in our
memories
fifty four thousand three hundred and
ninety five californians
who will never be forgotten about family
guess what there's millions and millions
of
did just want to go to a goddamn dodger
game right now
54 000 900 and if the wwe got to hold
them to be 67
300 it'd be a stadium record let me tell
you you got millions of people in that
state and you know what they'd [ __ ]
strangle
everybody they'd strangle everyone
sitting next to them
if they could go to a dodgers game next
month that's the truth
like you can keep playing this like save
lives hey man
but like americans have already been
like you took away any bit of like civic
pride we had any kind of nationalist
pride
we are now just fat
coming narcissist nihilist like that's
what our culture is now
like people that are just everyone's
like a victim and a crybaby and
everyone's just denialist
and now you're trying to sell us on but
hey man
you could potentially save a life and we
you've already
hyper focused our selfishness and all of
our [ __ ] worst appetites
into this like weaponized american
mindset
and now you're gonna tell us we can't go
to a [ __ ] dodgers game correct it's
not gonna work
no because we don't care like you've
turned us into sociopaths
so now you want us to be like hey man
save a life and the only people doing
that
are the other sociopaths that just love
having something to go hey man
i saved a life seriously hey why don't
you put a mask on
consist those people there's nobody who
actually cares
family members and friends nor by the
health care workers who bore witness to
unimaginable tragedy
look we've made mistakes i i have made
mistakes
he's made a couple mistakes hey may hey
a [ __ ] governor recall
why do you think you've made what
mistakes have you made but we own them
we learn from them you never owned your
mistake when you went to the french
laundry you made excuses you lied you
said you were outside
you said it was in the safe zone you you
made 500
what mistake has [ __ ] governor
[ __ ] here ever owned
and we never stop trying after all
that's
that's the california after all that's
the that's the california
even the governors look like they're
auditioning to be in a [ __ ] hollywood
movie
everyone in california is such a [ __ ]
phony
i i really just wish snl was still funny
and they still made fun of both sides
because jason sedakis would have made
a phenomenal gavin newsom he would have
been so
good as like a smarmy gavin newsom like
like to let them eat cake gavin newsom
they could have done some amazing [ __ ]
with this guy in [ __ ] jason sedakis
somebody said well jacob scott show says
when will will our net play this guy in
snl
will arnett would have played would play
him really well actually that's good
spirit and i just want you to know we're
not going to change
course just because of a few naysayers
and and doomsdayers
so the california critics out there two
million people is a few naysayers
and doomsdayers who are promoting
partisan
political groups are the doomsayers
you're the ones that are
shutting everything down yeah based on
doom
yep as with outdated prejudices and
rejecting everything that makes
california truly great
we say this we will not be distracted
from getting shots
in arms and our economy booming again
this is a fight for california's future
but the economy is dead because of what
the [ __ ]
you did by the way there's nobody
everyone's muted so the clapping
in the background yeah you don't hear it
and it's probably not a great idea
but you can tell they were all
instructed to do it yeah this whole
thing is so creepy
yep this looks like it's from like a
paul verhoeven film
yep you know when this pandemic
ends and it will end it's gonna it's not
gonna go back to normal
body language i think we all agree
normal was never good enough
you know normal accepts inequity that's
why latinos
are dying from covet at a higher rate
than any other racial
or ethnic group what
yes go ahead latinas are dying
more of covet in the state of california
because latinos
are a majority in california
thank you next question that was that
was very easy you see how easy that was
of course that's like saying asian
people are dying
at a rate higher than white people here
in california would
because they're no majority yeah it's
literally just
mexicans and filipinos now that's an
entire state so
and while essential workers wages aren't
enough for them to afford the essentials
look our eyes are wide open to what's
wrong and so our journey
back must also be a path to close those
inequities
there is no economic recovery no
economic recovery
without economic justice see ron
desantis walk up on that stage and be
like all right man hey get out of here
with all that
talk anyway hey check it out uh my name
is ron desantis
and i'm declaring myself governor of
california
so no more masks go on out there
everybody just starts going like i don't
think he can and then he goes hey fill
up the stadium
yeah there's already people
there's already people at the beginning
so we don't have any teams ready i don't
know
oh you don't have two triple a ball
teams in this town
you don't have [ __ ] you're telling me
you can't go get 16 mexicans
and [ __ ] fill this place up that's
cool you know who i brought on my plane
tampa bay and the marlins they're here
they're going to be playing a little
game for you guys
we brought our own beer too yeah we got
it and none of your [ __ ] california
swill
let's go huge [ __ ] civil war breaks
out in this country because florida
just tried to take over california it'd
be amazing our governor just went over
and started order
and it would be funny we just shut up
start ordering people around and gavin
newsom was just
like he was just too uh intimidated by
his chad persona
to do anything like you're the governor
stop it i tried a couple times he just
keeps talking over me
he just keeps blustering over me i think
he's been drinking